let's look at this clock and see if we
can tell what time is shown on it
first thing when we look at a clock we
have two hands and that's because time
is told in two parts time is told in
hours
that's part and on a clock the hours are
represented by the shorthand
and then the other part is minutes
and on an analog clock like this one
minutes are represented by the long hand
so let's look first at hours we have
this shorthand and it's between the six
and the seven
what that means is it's after six
o'clock but not quite seven
because our hand started at the top and
it worked its way around and it's gone
past six o'clock but it's not seven
so it's six something
it's six something it might be 6 15
might be 6 45 we'll figure out the
minutes next but we know it's after six
o'clock but not a seven so we'll put a
six in our hours place
then for minutes we have this longer
hand which is pointing right here
at this mark
and minutes again start at the top and
work their way around but now each of
these little spaces is one minute
so we can go one two three four five and
when we get to this first square this
first where this one is we've gone five
minutes
let's keep going like that 6 7 8 9
10 at this next one and maybe you see a
pattern here
every time we get to one of these
numbers or the squares the bigger marks
we've gone five more minutes so if we
keep going
this will be 15 minutes past the hour
keep going
20
keep going 25.
now we can't go all the way to the 6
because our minute hand stopped here it
hasn't reached this part so after 25
we'll go back to counting by ones the
one minute we have 25 26
27.
the minute hand has gone past 27 of
these marks meaning it is 27 minutes
past the hour
let's try another one
the hour hand is between the four and
the five which means it's after four
o'clock it's some amount of minutes
after four but it is not yet five
and now let's look at our minute hand
the longer hand represents minutes
so the minute hand started at the top
and it's gone five
ten
fifteen not quite to 20. so let's go
back to 15
and then count by 1 16 17 18
19. our minute hand lines up to 19.
so it is 19 minutes after 4 or 4 19.
on this one i encourage you to pause the
video and see if you can figure out the
time
okay let's try it together now
so the hour hand between the seven and
the eight
so it's after seven
but not quite eight and by looking at
the hour hand we can see it's quite a
bit after seven because it's almost
eight and looking at the minute hand
confirms that the minute hand's gone all
the way to here it's almost back to the
top
and that minute hand starting at the top
has gone
5 10
15 20 25 30 35 40
45 and then one more
46 minutes past
46 minutes past seven the time is 746.